President Trump goes to Capitol Hill
today in a new push for his biggest
domestic priority the tax overhaul
Senate Republicans hope for a vote this
week on a bill but it's not clear if
they will have enough support for it to
pass Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill
with why some Republicans are not on
board Nancy good morning good morning
Republicans can only afford to lose two
votes in the Senate and right now GOP
leaders are scrambling to accommodate
the holdouts Senator Ron Johnson of
Wisconsin and Steve Daines of Montana
have already said they will not vote for
this bill in its current form they worry
that small business owners are getting a
worse deal than big companies under the
plan corporations would get a sizable
tax cut in the plan but that's not going
to help small business owners who have
to pay individual taxes directly which
Johnson says affects over 90 percent of
American companies now these two
senators say they are willing to change
their votes if the bill is changed but
making those changes could put GOP
leaders in a bind because it would cost
even more money that they then have to
try to make up somewhere else this bill
is already projected to add one point
four trillion dollars to the deficit
over 10 years the president himself is
going to be working to win over some of
the holdouts today when he comes to have
lunch with all the Republican senators
the second time he's done so one
perennial wildcard however who does seem
to be on board is Senator Rand Paul of
Kentucky he announced he is going to
vote for the Pitts for the bill and the
president issued a personal tweet of
thanks in response Norah all right busy
day for you Nancy thank you so much